jordan lyles on the mound for the
rangers tonight this will be his 20th
start of the season seeming to find his
stride here in the middle to late part
of the season through 109 pitches his
last timeout his second most
miles
strikes out calhoun to strike the ball
game tonight one away
1-1
got a breaking ball that one on the
ground sharply hit out there to avonyas
and he throws out van meter they're two
away
mate pitch of the attack to cabrera and
this one on the ground out to short
right field and again ibanez is there to
one two three
for jordan lyle it's man bomb on the
mound yeah there you see there 14 games
four and six
record 5.09 he's got to have that slider
working today got to keep it down
against this rangers lineup game history
going
runs this one in the air to left field
for david peralta
doug mathis the pitching coach
that's a breaking ball left out over the
plate var shows in center runs it down
right back to first down number two
right there called strike three
and bumgarner strand blood-out walk
david in left field today knocked in a
run with a sacrifice fly yesterday
david peralta sends one deep to right
center
david peralta it's gone and there it is
his first home run since may 15th
it had been exactly 58 games and
215 played appearances since his last
home run
and the diamondbacks strike first
see the spin on the baseball and
out over the outer half of the
plate well we saw the hit one off the
wall a couple of times gonzo on the last
home stand that one got into the bullpen
for number five on the year
there's a little squib shot everybody on
the other side of the field matt baume
has to hustle and he can't get there man
a little slow out of the gate that time
gonzo
gesture broke the first base umpire
perfectly positioned to make that call
trying to get the tag on there let's see
if they want to challenge this
umpires are huddled up now
let's see does he get the tag on first
[Applause]
i think they did
yeah boniez is out
trevino hitting 226 three home runs and
17 runs ban it in
the one-two pitch and that's hit hard in
the left field and it falls in front of
peralta for the base hit so trevino
smacking a curve ball out into left
around him 1-0 count on martin
who pops up the bunt attempt walker
makes a sliding grab
[Applause]
houston walker comes in and gets
underneath that one at the last moment
trevino stays put at second really a
nice play nice sliding play right there
by walker
you see he's trying to get that runner
over to third and bunk for a base hit
basically at the same time
[Applause]
got it in there against the righty and
walker's there
[Applause]
didn't quite get that fastball in as
much as he may have liked but
white skies at the center for varshow
and madbum is through three holding a
one-nothing lead
all right bottom half of the fourth
inning and adolesce garcia to get it
started you want to make sure to get one
down but he was just baiting them to hit
a double that's right that one to the
alley and left rolls out there slowly
and garcia
will be content with a leadoff double in
the fourth inning
two strike pitch that one on the ground
and through into left field base hit
he'll wave garcia the throw coming
into the infield cutoff
low drives in a run
and the rangers have tied it one to one
[Applause]
two strength pitch in this one in the
air other way tahoe going back through
the wall
off the fence
low to third base ibanez slides into
second with a double
don't know if he was trying to hit that
hole and obviously seeing a pitch
here's the 01.
swinging a drive by culberson into left
field peralta goes back reaches up makes
the catch low tags it third and he comes
in to score a line drive sacrifice fly
to left for charlie culverson gives the
rangers a two to one lead
backs move 3-2 martin hits it hard to
center field backing up as varsha's
still going back near the fence makes
the catch banging into the 410 sign
for out number one that's about as far
as martin can hit it stop by
ballpark out barcelona center field you
see him get a good break and then he
actually takes a peek at the wall
to figure out how much room he has nice
play right there 410 to that part of the
ball we talked with torrey before the
game today about the ballpark and right
away he said it plays big and you can
see that just on television
and joey gallo who was scratched from
the lineup today levi weaver of the
athletic
broke the news that
he was scratched because of a
trade
he's not yet been announced by either
team with the yankees josh van meter
leads off the seventh he gave me that
and meter jumps on one and it's over the
head of whiting right field van nader on
the move
and he's in there at second josh van
meter we just talked about guns though
when his last at bat he can pull the
ball with some power
[Applause]
van meter takes off
and he's in there
[Applause]
andrew young drives it to center garcia
is there van meter coming in to throw
into third
and we are tied at two andrew young the
smasher gets the rbi
after bar show the center fielder
tonight as fly down twice over two
marshall gets into one dalton varsion
goodbye
diamondbacks take the lead
100 almost 110 off the bat 109 a slider
he gets more impressive lefty lefty
situation for dalton that's his fifth
home run in his last 11 games and it's
three to two diamondbacks
so after two strikeouts a walk in a
single winning runs aboard and the
batter is the catcher jose trevino
line to third van meters there the
d-backs get the win
tyler clifford hangs on and gets the
save his first since july of 2018.
the d-backs get the split in texas they
win a one-run game gonzo three two the
final